you was a mobile Christian family yes
OSU's Christian yeah okay so what made
you okay so you saying you was for
example like I just I'm interested in a
way rolls off my tongue when I say like
when I say it's slow or fast even if I'm
not pronouncing it right but just the
fact that it's it's role of my tongue in
a way that sends a certain vibration
that's interesting
whenever this game of chess was created
is there anything is there anything in
the Quran that would be related to all
of us
just yeah you know I said now I started
losing my money every week you know
because at the time I was working for
the telephone company I would lose
between 158th to like 250 a week so what
is that coming
yeah so this would make you this would
be a substitute for cabinetry no it's
not Gamelin 50 anymore it's more like
grinding no I mean like did this help
you get away for it yeah as we get away
from it all do the main reason why I
like chess because it's you know it's
good for it I like the social aspect
like outside parks like the most most
cool part like this is a cool part
Washington Square Park that's a cool
part on 35th Street Saint Nicholas Park
those are all good parts where like this
is for the most part it's good energy
you know I can meet interesting people
you know people in entertainment
industry dances you know musicians you
know people with careers
I mean that's lawyers I'm sitting down
with you know with people that have like
a salary me so I feel important and it's
just you know just the energy of the
press
pretty much
okay I couldn't look back it was just
the complexity of it and associates
people it's just it's amazing
was it just it was rock most people over
my last name is rock rock rock honey
Ellis is actually Leonard rock yeah so
how do you become I'm actually one of
the father started
yeah cuz me me and uh for my friends we
came out we actually wasn't over here he
was over there by the Gandhi statue yeah
so we just set up gonna be a good good
place to play in peace and after about
three months of set up every day yeah
one person came along and said I I three
people came along to set up and before
you know it like within three or four
months it was like ten to twelve percent
never stopped it just came out here you
know a lot of people I don't really get
into a lot of my associates personal
life but most come on the streets own on
some really need this you know to make a
living yeah I mean like I have a regular
job so you do concierge work I'm a
security guy I work in a financial
district oh no so I do this I do this
work here for a good pastime but you
know as a professional I still want to
get compensated for my time
oh yeah but it's a time when I'm sitting
down you know
I like to just you know meet people that
are interested in animate in one day and
one in 24 hours like on my own all days
I'll come out here like eleven twelve
o'clock right I probably won't leave
until like maybe I don't know three
o'clock in the morning on a good day
warm day you know was insane and
everything going on
there's cool but you know when it's when
I have to you know what this cold is
crazy I may steal for maybe three or
four hours
yeah there's rain any comment yeah we
have that we have that kind of thing in
in in London we have speakers corner we
have some she's got speakers going on
really
so Stimpy's really it's a historical
place we live over 150 years all kind of
figures have been there it's a corner
where different people from different
backgrounds come and you have dialogue
and discussion so when you go home if
you watch she wants you to barrage
speakers corner
yes London you see our videos so we
would remain it operate on YouTube and
have dialogue discussions like that will
start we just say our own organization
me
Hammad our teachers I made check my mat
is PR and some other people as well who
helped us we started all this alarm to
sharing affection mercy we need to know
you know on this side is just so you can
learn from you are usually in life so
basically okay and we don't have time
ten minutes died yet he was saying that
he was working a Christian family yeah
sorry
he was brought in a Christian family
yeah grew up in a Christian family you
know Mike okay so I have a mixed
background my dad my dad is from the
West Indies I'm st. Vincent yes my mom
is from Dominican Republic from the
cabin which is from Santiago yeah I
don't force me I'll speak the language I
was kind of like lazy at school when it
came to like linguistic system but you
know I think most Americans grow as
Christians and I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
Jesus as the Son of God
yes you can't get to yes the Creator you
know just without do something has to me
through Christ yes you're not Christian
meaning Christ like I guess that's what
the word Christian means Christ like so
what
but when I stopped was when I did my
first semester in college you know I
started talk with a lot of the students
Muslims Muslims Jews you know just the
whole the whole spectrum of religions
and I started picking up little pieces
of information here in there and over
over a short period of time a lot of the
information that's in the Holy
Scriptures is kind of inaccurate it's
kind of like little distorted
sososo for yourself to pay into yeah so
basically you're saying that you was you
was basically mobile Christian family
yes
Christian yeah okay so what made you
question people you saying you was for
example even stopped me speaking there
first
so you stop pushing scriptures yes so
what happened is a friend of a friend of
mine I won't really call him Abreu but
he's a real knowledgeable guy oh then he
was telling me a little bit in history
about Islam like he said that the first
Mohammed the first Muhammad died from
way way way way back he said that that
Muhammad at one point and I'm talking
out of 101 guy guy doesn't really know
much about her garage that is gonna fool
my French only years ago
yes as a teenager he said that Muhammad
forced religion on others he said that
if you don't if you don't accept Islam
as your faith then it would be murdered
this is what I heard it was gonna kind
of do me off you know is when I think of
Christianity as a kid got a little
Sunday school you know you sing the
songs and everything and you thinking
I'm sorry he didn't know he was gonna
Muslim he's just like Abu he's like one
of those like more like he's more like
Taoism yeah so I think it's misinformed
is a very bad yeah yeah that's the one
of the reasons we're here to you know
educate people
yeah so that that kind of deter me from
harm from getting into Islam okay just
affect the story talking about Mohammed
was like yeah it's so far from the
Christianity you know with politics
politics most politicians deal with
Christianity I think it's a Christian
country yeah I would say it's a
Christian country
politically most people in politics that
are high up the big hand in the skies so
to speak a Christian and any look at
Muslims as terrorists you know the whole
9/11 thing they look at you know maybe
this Arabic speaking or as the thing
irani hey every time in times you always
need a common enemy
right it's just how can now is the
Muslim said it was a black before now
the Japanese and then it was a Russian
yeah now there's a Muslim Stern now
exactly yeah so okay you went you you
looked at some scriptures yeah and and
you decide you do realize at this moment
of time that Christianity maybe have
corruption you said you said there was
some question in Scripture yeah you know
okay now you think of Judaism that's but
I believe Judaism deals with the deter
ah the five the first five books about
yeah and that kind of makes sense when
you when you when you when you listen to
the stories you know Moses and even you
know when you but you you think along
all of these like prophets like later on
in the scriptures you know it kind of
makes sense what but then when you get
when you get further down into the
scriptures when you talk about visions a
person having visions and any of even
when you look at a version of the Bible
you have the King James Version is but
these are people that that I've heard
more artists these are people that dealt
in like all kind of twisted sexual
activity
so anytime you're dealing with um
gentlemen that they're dealt in that
type of lifestyle we have the question
when they published the the description
you know you know even his own enemies
which testify they hated his guts and
the reason they hated it so much is
because he just came with a message of
worship God alone because if you look at
all the prophets that came even in
thousands of prophets came here every
one of them proclaimed something there's
no shadow of a doubt worship God alone
there is God has no partners so well
first of having feast upon him came he
came the same message they didn't like
that because they worship a hundred and
fifty five coats yeah and they were
using it as a business so they offered
the prophecy service ever will give you
a woman you will give you a woman he
once stated looking he stays you what
money would give you money just be quiet
and he said if he give the son in my
left and the moon am i right
I will not stop preaching one preacher
yes because it wasn't about money
it wasn't about woman or the statuary
I'm trying to say he believed in his
message he was known to be asada so
truthful that he would go to his people
will go to his tribe here is it my
children was my turn he played the night
yeah he went he went to it do you want
to take your office before I tell you
this he he went to his tribe and he said
if I told you guys right behind this
mountain there's an army coming to kill
us over would you believe me they said
of course we believe you we know you to
be the true for one we've never had
never seen
like somebody trustworthy because I'm
telling you I'm The Messenger of God
do you not worship anyone besides him
but you call me a liar if I told you
there's an army coming behind this
mountain you say yes of course how could
we tell you you're a true your but when
I come and tell you I'm the messenger of
put it in I mean so that was one of the
main fundamental things the Prophet
peace upon him came with yet worship
none other than God alone and when I
spoke to you you said you can test this
lamb or you believe in Allah I believe
in Allah so would you define yourself as
a Muslim or would you say that you're
not a Muslim but him but tell me white
of luck while I love but while here well
because they you know from the
information and have the the minimal
information and I've read from the Quran
as opposed to the King James Version
yeah it just seems in it it makes me
feel comfortable and it's and it seems a
more accurate more logically it hasn't
seemed like it's coming from a bad place
so certain certain certain certain
certain paragraphs from the King James
Version yeah kind of make me question
that may only be the same for the Quran
but it's just that I have yo I have it
I haven't those into the Quran that deep
yet to really to really make it
accessible the same it's just yeah this
is not a weight the uncomfortable has
James Version understand but but but
with the the people that I see all right
put it like this
when you have a mass amount of people
that's that's one religion like take
take a mass amount of Christians yes
they take a mass amount of Muslims
you're just gonna deal with what you do
truthfully you know so many difficult
message right it's the the energy that I
get from from each side okay okay
for example when I was growing up
Christians used to always try to
persuade you into become a group of
Christian yeah it's just like no matter
what they did it it was almost like that
Jehovah's Witness you always like when
you're normal and they kind of like
they're a little bit too aggressive and
that's the same thing with Christianity
not as aggressive as Jawas witnessed
what is that aggressive nature that I
don't like okay you did I mean if I was
going to convert I will convert to a
religion that's that's a welcoming okay
that's it so what was it how did you
take on the mettle of Trinity the
Trinity ever come like before you know
like you mean like the Sun father in the
Holy Spirit yeah cause if he is what
made you say you know what I believe
then the one true good what was it that
said the Trinity was like do you have
the truth about him yeah yeah I don't
believe this and I never really
understood the concept but it's funny
they know the father when you think of
when you think of the Dom the symbol the
honk
yeah his manly man woman and offspring
that makes sense yeah yeah
but do you think of the Trinity when I
think of the Holy Spirit like what
exactly is a Holy Spirit like I don't
everybody understood death that could be
fully explained to me then maybe I could
have a little bit more endearing feel
for unity they say is the Father
father's God then the father sent his
son then his son became the father so
the father is God God sent his son then
his son became good okay and the son God
died on the cross for the sins of the
world but at the same time this the Holy
Spirit which is also good but they're
not free goods were the one good does
that make sense to you
it doesn't exactly make sense okay so
now this is one of the big problems with
our Christian friends what we say is
this idea where did this notion come
from because when we look at Abraham
Abraham wasn't a Jew
it was an accretion always knew he was a
Muslim in the concept of the tide has
given because Muslim means the one who
submits his will to God right so
everyone didn't have these religions but
if you look in to all these prophets all
of them never came with this one of them
came and said like if he came to me said
to me what is it's time I say we believe
in
but there is nothing like it he does not
beget nor is He begotten yeah he does
not have a son he does not have a child
he's free from any needs right
yeah does that make sense to you yes
okay so this is where we come to our
Christian friends and say look what
you're claiming doesn't make sense who
you're claiming God came to earth
I can't mean worship God because he's
worthy of worship yeah because he's the
most powerful he's created all of this
right he deserves to be worshipped is
somebody who came to earth eat food and
that's about 20 deserving of my worship
we say no so that's what Islam is
international buyer so that's the reason
why you say you believe in Allah right I
mean it makes sense yeah in India in
like missis's
in their cold they take they consider
God the or so that's that's that's
that's pretty similar to to the Islam
like everything that's really big comes
from I never understood and another
reason why I'm I don't see myself
Christian now it's one one thing that
was important is that why is it that
they say that that jesus is the son of
it should be the son of man I think this
Jesus to be the son of man you can't
defy the laws of Lords of gravity you
know like walking on the water and a
healing the sick and all today I'm not
saying it can't be done it's just yeah
tom is right you know we believe in
miracles as well well he left you said
before being the son of God book doesn't
need the Sun to be I'm trying to say God
can do whoever fits his majesty you can
tell state but he's not going to come to
earth this doesn't negate oh if he's so
good why can't he come to earth because
it takes away from his majesty and how
is either all-powerful all-knowing that
if Jesus is the all-powerful and
all-knowing he was crucified on the
cross so God was crucified by the his
own creation his own creation God God
the Wonder imagine us we come to gonna
say we're gonna put him crucified that
can't even help himself that he's
crucified by his own creation and then
his crane dream genesee right actually
so did the Jesus that's in I thought
that I thought it was the same Jesus
tell two different Jesus there's two
different Jesus which is the Jesus in
the Quran and the Jesus an Akkadian
version are two completely different
beings I will not see two completely
different because even if you look into
the Old Testament for example in in in
the Bible when Jesus came we believe
there's some treatment because we
believe Allah God Almighty sent down
Jesus and Moses an Abraham and send the
Scriptures but the Scriptures were
corrupted in China the Quran there was
the Old Testament right there was the
final New Testament we say the Quran is
the final testament you get it piranhas
come to clarify the rooms in the Bible
yeah because God Almighty sent it or the
writer says Moses Moses and Jesus but he
did not preserve it he's not contented
preserving it was for those people at
that time so when the message was region
it went through corruption that's why
Allah says in the Quran woe to those who
write the scriptures with their own
hands and say this is from Allah so what
they seen is you're doing that for are
you changing the words of Quran the
friend is on a whole different evil
because it challenges people that doubt
it it says if you think this book is
other than your Lord then bring the
chapter like it bring something similar
to it so the smallest chapter in the
Quran is three sentences
three sentences and God is given the
challenge and say look if you can if you
doubt this book okay
we'll make something like a three
sentences or find contradictions or eras
energy game China same yeah so that's
the reason why the believers estimate in
time in 2000 2012 2013 December that's
when I came to Islam and when I don't
see a major Christianity this is one of
my issues it didn't make sense and when
I love that Jesus you said to the Jews
hear o Israel our Lord God is one he
didn't say hear o Israel our Lord God is
three in one the Father the Son and the
Holy Word no he said hero his own words
for this one when somebody came and
approached him they said oh good master
what must I do skater no laughing so why
calling me good there's only one with
and that's good alone so when we look
into it about the question I asked about
Jesus the same as wasn't for her there's
similarities because Jesus did teach the
oneness of God but it got corrupted by
poles but my girl yes Pokeball dear poor
poor logical yes the easy one who came
and brought this whole thing of a had a
vision of Jesus and He died for our sins
all of this that's why the Quran came
to correct that it's fake and yeah
that's why it sound like video clothes
like the thing is we believe in the
oneness of God and we believe that's
teammates masters programs program
within ourselves you get it
you call that the fitrah that filter on
the fitrah they made this position
trying to say yes
biologically you know you're like come
on like God come be free and one cause
Allah says in the Quran if there was
more than one good they would fight each
other for power Yugi I'm trying to say
right so logically where you're coming
from is that look one king right that's
one king there's not you know there's
less free of these but there's not free
there's one to get it right there's one
king he's the king of the heavens in the
earth and what we do in Islam Salaam is
with all people to worship Him and him
alone you get it because your mum and
dad brought you to this age their least
that you can do is appreciate and value
them respectful two of them yes what
about the one who gave you your mother
father G I'm trying to say Oh God
Almighty one's for you and me it's to be
grateful yeah cuz we pray five times a
day
you know and you know we fasting Ramadan
especially I'm trying to save so if you
not cause yourself as a Muslim but you
believe in Allah as your yes yeah that's
quite interesting yeah you know what's
funny thing is with about linguistics is
that like well like okay so like when I
did my first semester at Burma and
Community College right yeah like even
even as a teenager certain sounds and
certain words that roll off your tongue
is interested me and it confused and it
makes me gravitate towards that like
like for example like when you say the
word
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah like I just
I'm interested in a way rolls off my
tongue when I say like when I say it's
slow or fast even if I'm not pronouncing
it right but just the fact that it's
it's roll of my tongue in a way that
sends a certain vibration that's
interesting they're saying like the
English language you know I think you
know the Ebonics which is which is like
like a ghetto made-up slang it's good I
love it and I embrace it because it's
like it's certain words that you could
create and make up and get that same
vibration yeah so that's one of this
kind of like strange reason that's why I
gravitated towards Islam religion
because it makes sense it's logical and
it and it's just that you know I have so
much on my plate it is kind of to feel
like maybe I should you know dig more
deep into you know have you listened to
the Quran before we say listen to you
mean like do ya know do me a favor yeah
there's a lot of recited